okay Manisha I can have you kick out the
next question which is what you think
it's important to get done in the
kickoff meeting with the client right so
it's actually come somewhat related to
what we talked about in terms of the
first meeting kickoff but a few things
first of all it's nice if you can get
the entire team to come it can be
challenging sometimes to find days but
it's really good because you really want
everyone on your team to sort of feel
engaged with the client and it's much
easier if you're all there and you've
met face to face not always possible but
good to try form and I would say the
same thing on the client side because
you will have one or two primary people
of contact but often there are more
stakeholders involved the board may be
the for example just the example that
April was given you know there might be
one executive director you're dealing
with but it's really the board who
thought they wanted to hire you and it's
good to have them there because one of
the things you want to do in that
meeting is you've worked out a work plan
you kind of know what the goal is but
you want to clarify it and sometimes
things change between the time that you
setup your work plan when you met with
them and when you actually have your
team kickoff meeting and it's always
good to have all the possible
stakeholders you can have there so that
we can all get to know each other and
kind of make sure that we have mutual
clarification on the goal the other good
thing about having all the act team
members there is related to what Cynthia
was saying which is it's really good for
your client to know why you're there
because from their perspective you're
doing this free work are you really
going to be interested are you going to
be engaged with them and it's good for
them to know why you're there for
example with my client that we're
working with I'm really interested in
education and to let them know I've done
a couple of projects in education so I'm
going to be pretty engaged at that level
for someone else to say you know that
this is a new area for me and I want to
learn about it or whatever it might be
it's just good for them to learn your
perspective as well let's see the goal
as I mentioned again you want to make
sure that you've clarified the goal and
made sure that we still agree upon it
because things just change all the time
in projects that's something you will
find I'm sure many of you had that kind
of experience kind of a middle thing to
do also is logistics in terms of you
know it's a good time to kind of find
out other events coming
that are going to affect the project you
know there might be again in this past
project that I was in summer came in
middle it's very challenging to work
with teachers and administrators of
school when summer is here and that was
an important thing for it has to time
our project around and it helps us to
set the expectations we said you know
we'd like to finish in October but we
have a feeling it will be detail and on
October as opposed to the beginning of
October so it's simple stuff like that
that can be good to kind of go over and
let's see what else do we have and the
other thing that's good to do is once
you've sort of gone through those basic
things is give them an opportunity to do
kind of an open Q&A with you just
questions that they might have typically
you will have had much more
communication with the executive
director but less so with the rest of
the board members or sort of ancillary
members who are kind of important to the
project but you're not going to interact
with them on a regular basis and this is
a good opportunity for you to understand
a little bit about their perspective and
find out if they have any questions
Oshin about understanding what's on
their horizon on the project we did with
the Japan Society do you remember that
they put on like an international
conference right in the middle of the
project and the executive director like
disappeared for three months and we did
not know that when we started the
project the only other thing I would say
about that first meeting with the client
is I recommend that you get a commitment
signed in blood from your primary
contact that they're actually going to
set aside the time to work with you you
know this is free and I actually wish we
charged them some minimal amount so they
have more skin in the game but one of
the frustrations in working with with
the clients for me has been that this
has just added on to everything else
that these leaders of the organizations
are expected to do and I would argue
that especially for the small ones
except I experienced the same problem
for a relatively large organization so a
clear understanding from the get-go that
this is going to take a lot of your time
and tell them with as much specificity
as you can what that commitment is going
to be and there are other resources like
one project they didn't have any money
for duplication of paper now this is a
few years ago but
you know they need to put something into
this commit to it and stick with it and
I think that first meeting is the time
in which you got to set that down just a
on our upcoming project one way to get
more commitment from the client is our
the Biodesign project has a two month
check point a go or no-go
both from the client side and from the
team side maybe that's from a psychology
class of the more times they say yes the
more committed if it's the right thing
to do if there's no money yes that's
right